esto es todo lo que queda
escombros de una violenta explosión en
el centro de Marsella que produjo el
derrumbe de un inmueble
Michelle de 83 años vecina del edificio
de ruido pensó que se trataba de una
bomba
anuncia una detonación pensé que habían
puesto una bomba en algún lado debajo de
mi apartamento porque fue muy fuerte
la señora de bullette se solidariza Con
quienes Perdieron su vivienda
estoy especialmente triste por todas las
personas que fueron desalojadas que
tuvieron que dejar su apartamento y los
que quizás ahora están bajo los
escombros
las causas de la detonación no están
claras la fiscal de Marsella Dominique
lorens direcciona la investigación hacia
una posible fuga de gas
obviamente la explosión de gases parte
de las pistas porque fue una detonación
extremadamente violenta
pero es algo que en este punto de la
investigación todavía no podemos afirmar
las operaciones de rescate han sido
lentas debido a la persistencia de las
llamas bajo los escombros varias
autoridades han arribado a la zona como
el ministro de vivienda Olivia Klein y
el interior llegará
la indignación crece en la población
marselleza no es la primera vez que el
derrumbe inmuebles causan tragedia en la
ciudad costera en noviembre de 2018 ocho
personas murieron por el derrumbe de dos
edificios en malas condiciones la
segunda ciudad más poblada de Francia
tiene serios problemas en las
infraestructuras Marsella ha vivido
varios derrumbes fatales en los últimos
40 años en barrios de escasos recursos
donde actualmente viven 40.000 personas
que estarían en riesgo según varias ong